the world's greatest criminal has stolen
the greatest treasures escaped the
greatest prisons and he bears a strong
resemblance to someone you know it's not
easy being mean its Constantine the
world's most dangerous project I'm going
to be here - why when do I do the indoor
Running of the Bulls
Dominic international tour manager
Dominic bad-guy podgy is French my men
will go down in history as great the
steep of allthe I mean our names right
of course my name first then spacebar
spacebar spacebar your name
Judith boys
you guys think that Kermit's been acting
a little weird lately
that's ridicuious killing the TV ad it's
what we say it ricky gervais time for us
and Gina this is my cow it is illegal
now go get some massive tires what so
many Hollywood stars it'll leave you
wanting more yeah no more only one guy
in this world who can save us
only one frog who can restore order
let's get out of here
bring justice and set things right you
are talking about commitment
CIA Interpol this is my truffle badge
here's my real badge you must have been
looking at the wrong veg you were
singing
Most Wanted I am NOT Konstantin I can't
see anything
you'll have to wait till I'm like out of
the hallway